the guy dropped the charges originally
that's our heard right what that's we
heard at first yeah and then you bring
them back i guess so
uh so we obtained video strongly after
alleged altercation showing sonam being
lewd away in handcuffs
as previously reported someone had
initially been slapped with five battery
citations over the alleged fight but a
judge in nevada dismissed the case in
january after the clark county district
attorney told us the citations no still
appeared failed to comply with the legal
requirements as set forth by nevada law
so they didn't go through with it
and um here are some
some of the details
but this is just from the las vegas
review journal yeah
well so that's where the report came out
but it's the guy that's suing this is
the guy's name is christopher steele
stealth flug or stealth flug yeah still
still flagged i don't know
before i read this
realize one thing i'm sure mr stealth
has his version of story and jail has
his virgin right there's two sides and
there's the truth i think there's
somewhere in the middle here right
uh civil lawsuit was also filed by
christopher and julie's stuff claiming
seemingly intoxicated sonan knocked a
drink out of his hand and then attacked
him without uh provocation or any
communication whatsoever so i was
wandering the hallway of the four
seasons hotel next to mandalay bay
barefoot wearing a torn bloody t-shirt
at the time
um then this man goes on to say the the
accuser says i just want people to know
it was totally unprovoked attacked
um he told the las vegas review journal
we were just walking in our room to plan
a sushi dinner we did nothing wrong this
guy went on a crazy rampage
god i just
have a hard time believing that that is
not in chelsea's dna
the lawsuit says another hotel guest had
to stop someone from choking mr step
plug only to get attacked and elbowed in
the face
so and then alleged attacked the wife
throwing against one punch her in the
face
the filings allege that several hotel
employees were also assaulted by sona
including security guard that was needed
in the face the other who was kicked in
the chest there's so much stuff going on
here it's insane
keep going down uh-huh that's the older
one yeah keep going down here
[Music]
um
hmm
yeah i it's just a lot to take in right
yeah um and said they are they had minor
injuries
my question would be
chael's selling every bit of probably
230 pounds
he hit this i i'm assuming she's
standard sized woman i don't know five
six hundred and thirty pounds
average woman
if chael saw and slammed against wall
and socked her in the face minor
injuries
okay
and the man so he he really punched him
in the face
and then the guy who was elbowed on the
ground from jail sonin
minor injuries
okay and they said hotel employees got
into it so i i haven't heard anything
about hotel employees this first time
i've heard of it yeah also
i stay at four seasons nice hotel
where's the security footage it's in the
hallway there's there's cameras
everywhere where's the camera this is
very easy to solve
where's the four seasons hotel security
footage
i'd love to see it
um again i think there's this guy's
version of story trails and the truth
somewhere in the middle i wasn't there i
don't know clearly chael's a close
friend i'll defend chael til something
else comes out
um
this is how i operate yeah you know i i
don't know what happened there known
chill i have a hard time
hard time a guy has no history of
violence outside the afghan that
randomly picked this innocent family and
punched both them in the face i have a
very hard time believing that
very very difficult time believing that
and if he did
minor injuries
that's okay
that's where it's a little weird there
um
again i just i need i need more
information before you know but you know
i don't know this whatever his name is
you know i don't know this guy i know
chael and i'm pretty well joe's a very
good person very good dad very good
person
i'm gonna need more i i need more
evidence before i take this guy's word
i've never heard of
um you know crapping on chelsea
the story sounds insane too all that
chaos it just sounds pretty crazy insane
all right so jon jones tweeted something
then deleted it he mentioned your name
is uh name in it as well
so happy i don't think he added you come
on dude
i need my followers up son
oh so you mentioned dan hooker and you
because you guys are critical of him
obviously like everyone was about the
whole wife
hitting alleged wife hitting incident
even though the kids reported all that
stuff whatever yes yeah
uh so this is ch uh this is jon jones
talking yep and he deleted it he said
dan hooker bro how did why do people
delete stuff i don't know because it
lives in forever right now yeah so but
dan hooker brendan schaub is this what
you guys are jumping down my throat
about and what's it was talking about
this new these new details about chelsea
so then you go sorry but man everyone
their mom covered my story when i was an
[ __ ] in las vegas stoner allegedly
attacked his wife another woman along uh
with like five men and crickets
no not crickets not crickets um i don't
i don't know john person i don't i don't
know him like i know chill i talk to
chill all the time i've worked with jail
train with jail for years i know jail
very well i don't know john that well
john has a history a history yeah a deep
long rap sheet history of making some
mistakes
um
jump and what did i jump down his throat
about when his stuff came out the first
time this stuff came out with the the
kids the wife the yeah man when i hear
you know your daughter something like
that on the security guard don't let us
go back up there don't let me you know
that's where it affects me as another
dad
um
i would say i jump down your throat
trust me i don't jump down your throat
it's hard to defend when you know your
wife and kids are involved i can't
defend you i don't know what happened
there
um
there's just a there's a there's a
pattern here child doesn't have a
pattern so it's tough to defend jon
jones i don't jump down his throat i
think people make mistakes
um and i you know i'm very forgiving but
definitely don't jump down his throat
you know when you when you hear that
stuff
about john it's obviously way easier to
believe than trail sonin for for a
reason
i get you know fighters are sensitive so
dan hooker bench
dan hooker goes after him
oh
yeah
i i don't light him up
so dan hooker posted on march 27th
explain how this makes you any less
less of a piece of a [ __ ] and what do
you post that with that message
yeah yeah it's not like well look what
chael did
well no listen i'll tell you right now
if you show me a video from the
from the freaking four seasons of chill
hitting a woman or his wife
no one will jump more down his throat
than me i will light his ass up here on
the shop show i will never talk to him
again you touch a woman i'm out dude
that goes for john jones
chelsean anybody
anybody i don't [ __ ] with in any
capacity
so it's not like well where where's this
keep the same energy with jail
and i will if it comes out and the four
scenes like yeah here's the video we
obtained you know tmz is like here's the
video and chael's just going freaking
berserker bane mode yeah i'm out dude
i'm not defending that
right now the only thing i'm defending
is i know chael's character i know what
type of dad he is what kind of husband
he is what kind of person he is i've
been in the locker room with chael
sonnen i've been in training camps chael
sonnen i've worked with chael sonnen
when we both retired i know chael very
well
this is not in his demeanor to do this
so i definitely have skeptical hypo eyes
based off my personal experience with
chael sonnen when it comes to jon jones
there are many examples of him making
terrible life decisions that have
affected his career in a very negative
way so when reports come out it's hard
to defend because there's a rap sheet
there with chelsea it's easy to defend
because i know him personally and
there's no rap sheet there this is
surprising to anybody involved with jail
sonan in every capacity that's the
difference
but jump down your throat john now oh
come on dude and i still i still have
you pound for pound number one by far i
still think you're gonna be the
heavyweight champ of the world i even
after all this dude and i said i'd never
defend you after this after all this i
still want you to be the heavyweight
champion of the world i still think
you're me heavyweight champion of the
world i really do man
i think outside of
the octagon he's been out for what damn
near two years now i think outside that
his personal life is in shambles you
know he's talked about being lonely in
the house and it's like yeah dude you're
playing this game it's caught up with
you man it sucks to see i don't want
that for him i hope he figures it out i
hope maybe losing his family gets them
you know sober and gets them to figure
things out it sounds like he said he's
been sober right last time
so you know i'm
here the entire step we're rooting for
you man
not jumping down your throat but when
that stuff comes out and there's legit
reports that your kids are saying you
know don't don't let my dad back in the
room and stuff like that we got problems
man it's from one dad to another
it's a problem dude that's not good my
man
so yeah trail's much easier to defend
and the end of the day i know jail very
well i don't know john